[Music]
writing is a navigation tool in some
sense you think about where you're going
so you can test out the root before you
implement it that's all associated with
thought and the deepest form of thought
is writing it's the deepest form of
thought
[Music]
my students in my fourth year seminar
were very good students I asked them to
write three essays and the first essays
were they were terrible
I started to think through when I was
assessing an essay well what was I
assessing use the correct words
then put them in the proper phrases and
then the phrases should be organized
into sentences that are grammatically
coherent then you have to organize the
sentences within each paragraph and then
your paragraphs have to be sequenced so
that the essay exists as a coherent and
meaningful totality and so then I wrote
a guide to writing and just made That
explicit this is what you're doing when
you're writing and you have to edit at
every single one of those levels
when my students in my fourth year
seminar went through this process they
inevitably produced the best essay
they'd ever written
[Music]
so I took this writing manual I
discussed it a lot with my son and his
team that'll give me one that's more
conversationalist between you and me hi
I'm Julian Peterson
I wouldn't say founder of essay in that
situation though
hey I'm Julian I guess I might
so we started working on this how long
ago now on essay well we really started
working on it I think in 2019 you were
very interested in the idea of of
creating
Educational Tools online and we noticed
on your website that the document that
you produced for your students had been
downloaded 150 000 times so I was like
okay that's that's an interesting piece
of information
whenever we had thought about building
something based off of this document it
was always kind of like a course idea
but what would be really cool is to
build something that incorporated all of
the tools and philosophical elements of
that process and just build it into the
software
I do think it's a revolutionary program
in some sense because word processing
technology really hasn't changed that
much since about 1985.
essays value compared to other word
processors is that we offer a more
structured writing environment it's a
tool that will allow you to get your
thoughts down and then make sure that
they're clear and well structured we
really want to focus on the writer
improving their own ideas
[Music]
why didn't you decide that working on
this with me was a good idea
well I mean part of it was was that I
I know that writing is important
the impact of writing on oneself it's
the way you organize your own thinking
you can lay out what you think what do I
think
you just watch and you think okay I have
a problem what do I think about that I
think this I think this I think this but
I think this and I think this I don't
know much about that but I'm interested
so I better read this now I think this
you write all that down just so you know
who you are and then you think okay
let's sort this mess out
[Music]
create your character with your words
you mark your path forward with your
thoughts every word matters intonation
matters connotation matters poetic
Beauty matters and if it doesn't matter
then you're not writing and if you're
not writing you're not thinking and if
you're not thinking then you're going to
fall into a pit
that's how serious you are if you think
words matter and they matter they matter
more than anything
one of the reasons that we believe in
this product in essay is to help people
learn to work through their ideas before
communicating them University students
who are learning to write
well-structured arguments people trying
to write compelling emails people who
struggle with communication generally in
their careers if people got in the habit
of editing their writing and their
thinking and thinking critically about
their own ideas then you know the world
would be a much better place
to essay means to attempt to try it's a
lovely word to use as the signifier for
the program because we're trying to get
people to try amop man aim up and put
everything you have behind it
foreign
[Music]